- Cela fait maintenant 37 ans
que Mykola Pavliuk travaille
au barrage de Kozarovychi.
37 ans qu'il le considère
comme son bébé; qu'il en prend
le plus grand soin.
Mais le 24 fererer dernier,
il reçoit un ordre
particulièrement inhabituel.
Il doit trouver un moyen
d'élever de 5 mè l l le niveau
de la rivière Irpin, et vite,
pour empêcher une immense
colonne de tanks russes
de la traverser.
Oui, mais voilà : le barrage
n'est pas conçu pour ça.
"On a tout envisagé, dit-il,
percer un trou avec une to
ou une scie à béton.
Mais finalement, il a dû se
rendre à l'évidence : la seule
solution était de dynamiter.
Ilmemememe indiqué aux soldats
le meilleur endroit
où placer les charges.
"Je n'ai pas de regrets, dit-il.
C'était nécessaire.
Et ç'a marché : les soldats
russes ne sont pas passés."
Le dynamitage du barrage a eu
pour conséquence d'inonder
toute la région.
Le village de Demydiv
s'est retrouvé sous les eaux.
Des parties entières de
l'agglomération ne sont
accessibles que par bateau.
Heureusement, une pompe
installée récemment a permis de
faire baisser un peu le niveau,
ce qui a permis à Svitlana
de se rendre chez elle
à nouveau. Un retour difficile.
"J'étais incapable d'y mettre
les pieds, dit-elle. Mais mon
mari m'a dit que je ne devais
pas pleurer pour des
et des vêtements."
Svitlana craint que les
fondations de la maison ne
soient affectées; des dommages
qui pourraientrmrmrmrmrmrmanent.
Mais elle ne souhaite pas
en dire plus par pudeur.
"Notre malheur n'est rien
comparé à ceux qui ont perdula .
N'importe qui dans de telles
circonstances aurait tendance
à se considérer comme un
sinistré et à espérer
des réparations pour
les dommages causés.
Mais ici, les gens voient
les choses autrement.
Et s'ils reconnaissent avoir
souffert de cette inondation
volontaire, ils pensent aussi
que c'était un mal nécessair
C'est le cas de Hryhorii,
63 ans, le père de Svitlana.
Bien sûr, sa cave à légumes a
été inondée; sa vache et son
veau ont failli se noyer.
Alors, il avoue avoir été un peu
se mettre à monter.
Mais pour lui,
cela ne fait aucun doute:
le sacrifice était justifié.
"Bien sûr, Demydiv a joué
unelelelelelelelel dans le
déroulement des événements,
dit-il. Sinon, les Russes
seraient arrivés jusqu'à Kiev."
Un sacrifice qui est loin
d'être un cas isolé.
Dès les premiers jours de
la guerre, plus de 300 ponts ont
ainsi été dynamités à travers
le pays po
l'armée russe d'avancer.
Ici Jean-François Bélanger,
Radio-Canada, Demydiv